jerry was reading about a study that
looked at the connection between
smartphone usage and happiness based on
data from approximately 5 000 randomly
selected teenagers
the study found that on average the
teens who spent more time on smartphones
were significantly less happy than those
who spent less time on smartphones
jerry concluded that spending more time
on smartphones makes teens less happy
alright this is interesting so what i
want you to do is think about whether
jerry is making a valid conclusion or
not and why or why don't you think he's
making a valid conclusion
all right now let's work on this
together this is really important to
understand because you will see things
like this in the popular media all the
time that try to establish a causality
when there might not be causality or at
least where the study might not be able
to show causality so right now jerry is
saying he's concluding that smartphone
usage smartphone
usage
makes teens less happy so he's assuming
there's a causal connection smartphone
usage causes teens to be less happy
less happy
can he actually make that conclusion
from this study based on how it was
designed
well the first thing to ask ourselves is
is this an experimental study that is
designed to establish causality or is it
an observational study where we really
can just say there's an association but
we really can't make a statement about
causality
well an experimental study he would have
had to have a control group and then a
treatment group sometimes called a
experimental group so i'll say that's
control group that's the treatment or
the experimental group and then you
randomly assign folks to one of those
two groups and then you would make that
treatment group use the cell phone more
and see if they are less happy that's
not what happened here what happened
here was an observational study
in this study
we are looking at two variables
so you have your smartphone
usage
and then you have the teen happiness
and they took these 5 000 randomly
selected teenagers and they figured out
their smartphone usage and their
happiness maybe with a survey of some
kind and then you could plot those data
points would have 5000 data points
so this data point right over here would
be a very happy teenager that doesn't
use a smartphone much this would be a
not so happy teenager that uses a
smartphone a lot
and so you would plot those
data points and there might be a
teenager who's unhappy and doesn't use a
smartphone or one that is happy and that
uses a smartphone a lot
but you could see there's a trend
there's an association that in general
the teenagers who use the smartphones
more seem to be less happy and the
teenagers who use the smartphones less
seem to be more happy but it's important
to realize that the causality could go
the other way around
maybe less happy teenagers use their
smartphones more and maybe more happy
teenagers don't find a need to use a
smartphone or there could be some
variable that's not even being observed
in the study that has a causal
relationship with both of these so there
could be some other variable that might
cause someone to be less happy and use
their smartphone more so in an
observational study you can really just
say there's an association you wouldn't
be able to say that there is causality
so jerry is not making a valid
conclusion it's an observational study
we've only established an association
not causality